est en fait la nature n'est qu'un chat
gigantesque et si oui qui lui caresse le
doux
permettez moi de vous présenter le
brillant nikola tesla s'est réellement
le plus grande quant aux google nikola
tesla on obtient 34 millions de résultat
en gros ce sont les mêmes quatre photos
on trouve aussi des infos étranges ou
même parfait à metz par aider si vous
avez un briquet tesla je ne vous avais
pas vus et maintenant j'ai l'immense
plaisir de vous présenter un tout
nouveau système d'énergie le courant
alternatif
mon système va transformer le
fonctionnement du ventre d'étincelles
cet enfer ou cachés ou le courant
alternatif est une perte de temps
peu pratique est morte elle vivait dans
votre tête
comme tout le monde tu manques de
financements monsieur tesla considère
que je lui dois de l'argent par de quoi
50000 dollars d'accords anne morgan la
fille de jay pire pantoute morgen
une femme comme celle-là peut rendre
possible à tes rêves les plus fous
tous mes rêves sont possibles je vous
offre une limonade vous travaillez la
nuit dans un laboratoire secret vous
projetez des éclairs à partir de la
terre jusqu'au 6 c'est comme si j'essaie
d'apprivoiser un chat sauvage et que je
me retrouvais couvert d'égratignures
sanglante
vous aimez être griffes et si nécessaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le monde dans lequel nous vivons fait
partie d'un rêve qui était ce là à rêver
le premier
[Musique]